So, My friend sent me this text message yesterday.
Apparently the whole world is playing a Kardashian game.
*Acoustic Groove*
Kardashian Game... Oh, it's just Kim's game. I thought it was all of them... ok.
Downloading...
Do I do a dude? What's the point of playing Kim Kardashian game if I'm gonna be a dude?
I appreciate the fact that there are three shades of denim available.
Everything that is spelled with a "C" is spelled with a "K"
I need to start doing crossovers. I wanna buy Kanye swag.
*Reading out loud*
If this was true to life there would be a sex tape portion and a casting couch.
I, what am I doing/ How did I get here? like, what am I???
I'm late for an appointment to look at... I'm just accepting this like it's a normal thing! I'm like reading this like it's a F#&*@ing Bible!
Straighten shirt?... MONEY!
ooo, money came out.
Imma get that money.
What?.. am I a retail worker?
OH! Kim just got here!
Kim... Kim doesn't seem to have much going on this game.
Kim... Please.
She just wants someone to listen.
It's telling me to wait for Simon's call about a special gig.
Simon needs to chill out.
They want me to do photo shoots, they want me to do events. They want me to do these tasks and I'm running out of energy.
Willow Pape is my nemesis!
That's weird because she's going off about you and Kim on every social media outlet.
Whatever, I'm much to famous to deal with you gutter trash #ratchet... WOAH...
You reached the next level, you can now travel... *Laughing* I had to level up and now I'm allowed to travel to Beverly Hills.
Before it's like "Don't show your F#@$ing face in Beverly Hills!" But now I have the appropriate clout.
Level 8 and you go to Calabasas
Like, to do what? Become a suburban mom?
Hollywood is super easy, this is really inspiring actually.
I'm going to play this game a lot. A lot... I think that you've ruined my life.
Shit.. It just asked to like it on Facebook and I did.